so she wanted to have a spooky
wilderness themed
birthday party so i took them out
camping in the wilderness kim kardashian
takes northwest camping to celebrate her
ninth birthday it's really lit and fun
and crazy it gets wild and woodsy as
north brings along her whole crew for
the party
ready you're ready girl
hold on penelope from zip lining in the
woods to cozy campfires outside the
cabin camp north seems like the party to
be at aunt kourtney kardashian shares a
behind the scenes look on instagram of
just how much fun the family had ringing
in north turning nine years old there
were board games by the fireplace tea
time and the best part target practice
in a game of archery
yep
but that's not all mom kim kardashian
says this wasn't your ordinary camping
experience kim dished on the deets
during her appearance on the tonight
show with jimmy fallon she's really into
special effects makeup she does
like really good like wounds and scars
and really
she's really good at it i got her a
teacher to show her and get all of the
supplies so she wanted to teach her
girlfriends and we took about eight kids
eight girls and we went camping in the
wilderness and she wanted it to be
really spooky and she wanted
like these
mannequin heads
we've seen first hand north's makeup
skills on her joint tick tock with kim
gotta say we may have a beauty mogul in
the making it must run in the family
this isn't a big surprise since kim told
et she's been really into glam since she
was just a toddler she really isn't to
beauty she loves hair looks that's her
thing and she loves a little bit of
makeup and
um she was always really cautious of me
wearing makeup because she loves to like
smother me and give me kisses but i if i
have makeup on she's not having it do
her makeup nope
[Music]
kim also dedicated a b-day tribute
filled with sweet mother-daughter
moments throughout the years caption
there's no one like you the most honest
creative silly girl with the best heart
i just love being your mom
she's a gemini so she's a little bit of
both she definitely has kanye's outgoing
personality
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or
who it might offend and then she's also
really calm and sweet like me sometimes
[Music]
you